so it's a bit of a weird time to be
celebrating anything but we just passed
eight million subscribers I can't
believe that's eight million of you out
there the best video team is lucky to be
safely working from home right now we
are so grateful to the people who keep
the world running every day but we're
also really lucky that you are out there
and we know from the comments that the
people who watch these videos are as
curious and surprising and funny as any
audience that we can hope for we're
sharing a few things that have brought
us joy while we've been working from
home the past few weeks because we could
all use some of that because it is
spring this little bird nest on this
swing has a little egg in it
that's crazy a bunch of old pictures of
myself with my family and I've been
taking some time to scan all of them
just try to restore them make them look
a lot less dated like this one for
example it's just cool seeing them in
better condition hello and welcome to my
kitchen right now in New York City we
can't eat in restaurants unfortunately
but it has given me an opportunity to
cook a lot more and it's been something
that's really comforting for me for me
that's been coming to this park near my
house next to San Francisco Bay and you
get some pretty amazing views of San
Francisco which is where our office is
based but anyway hoping to get back into
the city at some point in the near
future something that brings me joy in
my neighborhood is this park and that's
my baby
[Music]
baking brings my roommate joy and eating
brings me joy so far we have had
focaccia and challah and scallion
pancakes of bread and now bagels which
[Music]
they're pretty good they're really good
they're really a lot of joy tonight I
[Music]
love this game
it's called lux it's basically a
computerized version of risk
I felt pride as I conquered my enemies I
recommend Lux if you want to escape
reality by destroying by your close
friends I'll do one more that's a little
less negative one of my joys have been
buying random size Bank because quality
is important but quantity is key when
you're stressed I'm not leavin rereading
some books that we already have this one
is called severance by Lang ma and it's
great it's actually about a virus in the
United States so it might hit a little
too close to home but it's great
[Music]
so just looks the best on camera it's
too much five is our head bites beard
head men's I am working from home with a
two-year-old who has a constant source
of joy this is what working from home
with the two-year-old basically looks
like so I'm gonna lock down in Delhi and
the thing that's making me the absolute
happiest are my niece's oh my god
eight million finding small excuses to
change out of my sweatpants
I've been scheduling the occasional
fancy zoom cocktail hour with some
friends calls with my grandmother no
worries ice your mommy how are you
[Music]
one thing that gives me joy is my
partner's garden here
I just really have so much joy and
happiness it'll just seem like happen in
this tiny inner compartment for me that
means playing the piano and repainting
all the rooms in my house there are a
few things that do bring me joy one of
them being my dog that we can still take
him for walks and being able to get to
my favorite hiking spot the other day
right now normally my family and I
celebrate Ramadan and my mom is Cara
stateside with us but she's unable to be
because most legs are suspended
so she's transported her cooking here
through FaceTime and I've been cooking
the recipes that she would normally cook
if she was here so here we go here's the
final product here's a thousand per side
and here's a last surprise for you guys
yeah to be honest a lot went wrong with
this cake but just wanted to say that we
love you from Fox on days when I need a
little fresh air and a little joy
up to my roof
[Music]
another thing that's been bringing me a
lot of joy is this sounded so
[Music]
and that brings me joy
thank you so much for watching as always
thank you for watching
blah bite
[Music]